أه لكنه لا يزال رقمًا ينذر بالخطر ، لا يزال هناك العديد من
الأطفال الذين تم الإبلاغ عن فقدهم في هذا الوقت
من العام
[ضحك] [
موسيقى]
لا أريد أن أثير قلق الجمهور من أن
الأطفال يتم اختطافهم عشوائيًا من
الشوارع أو  شيء من هذا القبيل أه
تعلم أن بعض هؤلاء قد يكون هاربًا
أم تعلم أنه لا يوجد دليل على
أي عمليات اختطاف في هذه المرحلة ، كان من الممكن أن
يكون لدينا تنبيه كهرماني أو
تنبيه خطر أو نوع آخر من التنبيه
[موسيقى]
لم أر هذا  من قبل ولكن هناك
دائمًا ما يدعو للقلق في أي وقت
تتزايد فيه الجريمة بعدد خارج عن
المعتاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أوه [
موسيقى] [
تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يحبس أنفاسك للاعتقاد بأن
من بين ستة أطفال من بين هذا العدد الكبير من الأطفال ،
يُحتمل أن يتم الاتجار بهم جنسيًا